so element 111 is the first were the
only element in the periodic table where
I've actually had to look up what the
name what the symbol stood for and it is
called roentgenium named after the
german chemist roentgen who physicist i
suppose who was the first person to
discover x-rays and whoever invented
named him it was a very good true
tributes to call the element after him
but as you can see it is almost
unpronounceable the same roentgenium
it's and you swallow half the words in
your mouth and roentgen discovered
x-rays at the end of the 19th century
and this caused an enormous excitement
because for the first time you could see
bones inside people's hands without
actually having to cut them open and you
could see things that people had
swallowed when they shouldn't have done
them and so on and what roentgens
connection with the element is I don't
know because after all there are only a
few atoms which like darmstadtium would
have been made by firing ions together
but nevertheless it's a good tribute to
him and the element is the last one in
the periodic table that has a formal
name and a symbol and naming it after
uniquely after a person or a place